the truth is out there The X-Files was a
game changer for science fiction
television becoming one of the first
shows of the 1990s to gain a cult fan
base through their early internet
starring David Duchovny and Jillian
Anderson as FBI agents investigating
paranormal occurrences The X-Files
premiered on Fox in 1993 and quickly
Rose to become the cult phenomenon that
it currently is however the show didn't
maintain its well-deserved praise
forever the ninth season of The X-Files
which aired between 2001 and 2002 was
victim to a drop in ratings and poor
reviews from television critics who
cited the series as lackluster riding
compared to its earlier more inspired
Seasons Fox pulled the plug on the
series Fox gave the X-Files a second
chance in 2016. Reviving it for a 10th
season with dakovny and Anderson
returning but following its conclusion
Anderson officially parted ways with the
show